-The chief of staff
to former
Vice President Mike Pence
was so worried that Donald Trump
would put Pence's
physical safety at risk
in the run-up to the attempted
coup on January 6th
that he told the Secret Service
about it,
a prediction that was borne out
when Trump sicced
a violent mob on the Capitol
and reportedly spoke approvingly
of the mob chanting,
"Hang Mike Pence."
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
The endless bad faith and lying
from the Republican Party
just keeps getting more
and more exhausting.
For example,
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
recently tried to blame
the Biden administration
for rising electricity prices
in his state, tweeting...
Two things -- first of all,
Texas has its own power grid,
where electricity is generated
and used only
within state lines.
So, Texas' electric grid
is separate
from the rest of the country.
You know, the way you
become separate from the country
every time there's
[ Laughter ]
a crisis in your state.
No surprise that Cruz is a liar,
though, doesn't he just
look like the guy
who shows up
in an Old West Town
[ Laughter and applause ]
and promises he can make it rain
if you give him
a few bars of gold?
[ Laughter ]
Then, the next morning,
when it doesn't rain,
a group of townspeople go
to his room
and find a note that says,
"So long, suckers!"
[ Laughter ]
So, they go to the stable
and he's still there
because he couldn't
figure out how
to get the saddle on his horse
[ Laughter and applause ]
and they just beat
the living crap out of him.
Doesn't he just look
like that guy?
[ Laughter ]
Second, Democrats,
much to the dismay
of progressives
and anyone who doesn't
want the planet
to turn into a climate
change-induced apocalypse
have not passed
the Green New Deal.
This is yet another reminder
that Democrats
should do more stuff because,
whether they do or not,
Republicans are going
to attack them for it.
They don't care if it's true.
Ted Cruz is going to bitch
about how Biden
outlawed red meat
and took his guns away
while he flips burgers
with the butt end of his AR-15.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When everyone rushed --
When everyone rushed
to fact-check Cruz,
he then followed up by claiming
that natural gas prices
have doubled because
of Green New Deal policies,
which, again, is insane,
since the Green New Deal
is not, and has never been, law.
In fact, if anything,
rising energy prices
are even more reason
to pass a Green New Deal,
so we can generate
our own renewable energy
right here in the U.S.,
instead of being held hostage
to global energy markets
dictated, in large part,
by oil-based autocracies,
like Russia and Saudi Arabia.
If you ask me, I'd much prefer
to get my electricity
from a wind turbine
or a solar panel on my roof
[ Cheering and applause ]
than a bloodthirsty dictator.
Plus, plus, wind turbines
have the added benefit
of annoying the [bleep]
out of Donald Trump,
[ Laughter and applause ]
who, notoriously,
[ Cheering ]
hates them and, and,
and thinks they sound
like this --
-Rirr, rirr!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I think --
I think he's confusing
wind turbines with cats.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Trump ]
Windmills go like this --
"Rirr, rirr!
Meow, meow.
[ Hiss ]"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Anyway, the point is
Republicans are shameless liars.
Well, I guess
that was the point.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it is "A Closer Look"
and that's usually
the point of these.
[ Laughter ]
Here's another example --
Colorado Congresswoman
Lauren Boebert tweeted
this incredibly dumb retort
to calls for more gun control...
And, yes, it's true,
it stands for ArmaLite rifle.
And, as someone who has made
that mistake myself in the past,
I would just like to issue
this sincere apology
to Lauren Boebert --
I'm sorry
for not giving a [bleep].
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, I love --
I love that the same people --
the same people who say,
"I don't care what your pronouns
are," also say --
[ As Boebert ]
Don't get the name
of my gun wrong!
[ Laughter and applause ]
My gun has feelings, too.
Anyway, the point is this is
the modern Republican Party --
a collection of ghoulish
conmen and weirdos saying
and doing whatever they think
they can get away with
to gain and hold on to power.
The most recent example
of this trend
is the fact that the GOP nominee
for Senate in Pennsylvania
is now officially
none other than Dr. Oz.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, how can you be
the best man for the job
when you're not even the best
"Oprah" doctor spinoff?
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm -- I'm not saying Dr. Phil
would be a good senator,
but at least he'd have a plan,
if your team
started dressing too sexy.
[ Laughter ]
I never thought Dr. Oz
would be a nominee
for anything other than
The New England Journal
of Medicine's annual
Craziest Doctor Alive! Issue.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This guy is
a notorious scam artist,
according to many
of his colleagues and peers.
When four out of five
doctors agree,
he's the other doctor.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, just like almost
every other
successful Republican politician
in the country,
Oz has learned that,
in order to thrive
in today's GOP
and court the Republican base,
you have to embrace
election denialism
by implying there was
widespread fraud in 2020,
when we all know
that there was not.
-The reality for me is 2020,
under the cover of COVID,
was an example of how you
should not run an election.
Here in Pennsylvania, people are
really worked up about it.
I already said,
on the debate stage,
I was the first to say
we cannot leave 2020 behind.
We have to get under the hood,
examine exactly what went down,
and address those issues.
There are so many different
things that happened.
As you really,
really examine it --
As a physician, you know,
I like to get
into the details.
I've talked to individuals
who say their votes
weren't counted,
who went to the polls
and claimed
that someone had already voted
with their absentee ballot.
We have got to understand
the different ways
where cheating occurred,
so we can, first of all,
identify how much happened,
but also make sure
that it never happens again.
-I understand that,
as a physician,
you want to get
into the details,
but there are also times
you just don't have to.
If a patient came in
and said their arm fell off,
but you could see
that it hadn't,
you probably wouldn't order
a full set of tests.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You'd probably, you know,
you'd send them off
to a different doctor,
who did, you know, brain stuff,
which is
[ Laughter ]
what we used to do to anyone
who said their vote
wasn't counted
because I doubt
these people knew that.
Did their sticker also have
tiny writing on it?
[ Laughter and applause ]
But this is the ideological
heart of the GOP --
conmen and scam artists
embracing the lie
that any election
they lose is illegitimate.
That was the lie that fueled
the coup attempt on January 6th
and the GOP is as committed
as ever to defending that lie,
a lie that we now know
almost got Trump's own
vice president killed.
In fact,
we just recently learned that,
even in advance of January 6th,
Pence's team was so worried
that Trump was intentionally
putting Pence at risk
of physical danger
that they alerted
the Secret Service.
-A stunning new report
in The New York Times says
that a top aide to former
Vice President Mike Pence
warned the Secret Service
that President Trump
could turn on the vice president
and the aide feared
for Pence's safety
on the eve of the Capitol riot.
The Times report claims Pence's
chief of staff, Marc Short,
warned the Secret Service
of his safety concerns
one day before the insurrection.
-This falls into the category
of one of those stories
that's both incredibly shocking
and not at all surprising.
I mean, of course, Trump was
putting Pence in danger.
That was the point.
He was threatening Pence
with physical violence,
unless Pence gave him
what he wanted.
The dude spent a lifetime
in New York real estate.
He knows how to act
like a mobster.
[ Laughter ]
You think he never sat
behind a desk,
threatening a city
planning commissioner
while petting a cat?
Or, in Trump's case,
Rudy Giuliani?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Giuliani ]
Oh.
Oh, that's right, that's right,
I love it right
behind the ears, boss.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Be quiet.
Be quiet, furry windmill.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In fact, even after the mob
tried to follow through
on Trump's directive
and stormed the Capitol,
chanting, "Hang Mike Pence,"
Trump didn't back down.
He ignored repeated pleas
from even the people closest
to him to quell the mob
and he reportedly even told
his then-chief of staff,
Mark Meadows, that he thought
maybe Pence should be hanged.
-Stunning new reporting
on the investigation
into the January 6th attack
concerning Donald Trump
and his reaction
to the chants
from his supporters
outside of the Capitol that day
to, "Hang Mike Pence"...
-"Maybe Mike Pence should be
hanged" is a reminder
that Trump is both a monster
and wishy-washy?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, if there's ever a time
to come down firmly
on one side or the other...
[ Laughter ]
...it's "Should we hang
the vice president?"
[ Laughter ]
I mean, Trump would've made
a terrible Queen of Hearts.
[ As Trump ]
Off with his head.
Or maybe,
maybe we leave it on.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A lot of people are saying,
"Get that head outta here!",
but you can also make a case
for keeping the head.
We love -- We love the head,
don't we, folks?
[ Laughter ]
It has, oh, so many great parts.
I mean, the eyes, the ears.
Don't forget the nose!
[ Laughter ]
And the most --
the beautiful mouth.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Remember, I mean --
[ Laughter ]
We're waiting for all of this
and more to finally come out
when the January 6th Committee
holds its first
televised hearings,
beginning this Thursday
in primetime.
Now, if you ask me, they
should've done this a while ago
and a lot more people should
already be in jail by now,
but better late than never,
I guess.
And, yet, the Trump team's
argument is mainly
that no one's going to watch,
a point former Trump spokesman
Jason Miller made
over the weekend.
-This is basically just
an echo chamber,
a lefty echo chamber,
where they think,
in their minds,
"Well, people at home
will stop what they're doing
at 8:00 pm at night."
No, you're getting the kids
put to bed
or getting done
with the homework
or you're watching sports.
We talk about the finals --
Stanley Cup or NBA.
You're going to stop and watch
Liz Cheney, Bennie Thompson,
Adam Kinzinger?
No.
Now, we're getting into the
summer. We're into June.
People have better things
to do in their lives.
-Dude, no one's expecting
millions of viewers
to change channels en masse
from the NBA Finals
to a congressional hearing,
and I don't blame them.
I'd also rather watch
the NBA Finals, even though
I'd think about Jason Miller
the whole time
because his head is the shape
of a partially deflated
basketball.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, no one should be
surprised that Congress --
Congress -- picked the worst
time to start these hearings.
I mean, way to wait
until the summer,
when people famously watch
the most TV.
"Oh, it's 85°.
Should we take the boat out
on the lake with a cold six-pack
or stay inside
to watch the hearings?"
[ Laughter ]
But no one's trying to compete
with the NBA finals
and that's not the point.
The point is to document
what happened in the lead-up
to the coup attempt
because Republicans
are going to try it again.
Do you think Donald Trump's
just going to give up
after almost getting his own
vice president killed?
Trump's like the Wile E. Coyote
to Pence's Roadrunner.
[ Laughter ]
Remember that insane
Oval Office meeting
where Pence sat totally still
with his eyes closed,
hoping no one would notice him?
[ Laughter ]
He learned that from cartoons.
What people don't remember
is that,
at the end of that meeting,
Pence held up a little sign
that said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
The shameless bad faith
of the GOP,
in trying to whitewash
an attempted coup,
remains both shocking
and also not surprising,
which is why we need a full,
clear, exhaustive account
of everything that went
into their plan,
so we can, hopefully,
stop it from happening again.
We need to sound the alarm now
and hope that everyone hears it.
Maybe it would help if the alarm
sounded like this --
-Rirr, rirr!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.